[Music]
there's a lot of theater to old-school
diplomacy as someone like Richard
Holbrooke during the Bosnian
negotiations at wright-patterson Air
Force Base in Ohio you know he had
luggage delivered prominently outside of
the doors of the American diplomats
present so that the other side would
think oh no the clock is ticking the
Americans are going to pull out you know
it was a complete feint but it worked
and it got people back to the table at a
tough time in the talks
you know diplomacy isn't a dovish
endeavor always and in that case this
was a State Department official who was
fully leveraging the threat of NATO
strikes you know and and doing a lot of
saber rattling a lot of larger-than-life
bellowing and threatening and cajoling
diplomacy doesn't always look pretty or
neat but it is absolutely an antidote to
and an alternative to military
intervention there are some fundamental
misunderstandings about what diplomats
do around the world and I think that's
been exploited by politicians of both
parties to characterize these brave men
and women as dusty bureaucrats you don't
get a lot done in fact these are
individuals who get very little pay to
uproot their families and move them
around the world and work in dangerous
places specifically to ensure our
security as a nation and they do
everything from screening the dangerous
individuals that seek to enter the
United States of America to brokering
the high-level political settlements
that hopefully can spare our servicemen
and women from being thrown into the
line of fire as a first resort every
time we encounter a conflict one of the
consequences of sidelining diplomacy is
you see a lot more of the work that was
once the domain of diplomats coming out
of the Pentagon and the CIA you end up
with the military-industrial complex
taking over the work of development I
served as a State Department official in
Afghanistan for instance and
in that conflict which was a
particularly militarized setting if you
wanted to do just about anything if you
wanted to start a conversation with
local leaders on the ground if you
wanted to build a well you had to do it
through the Army Corps of Engineers or
through the various teams around the
country that were called PR tease these
Provincial Reconstruction teams you know
where the military was stationed on the
ground and had access to those
communities we have created a universe
in which if you try to get something
done through the State Department or
USAID you end up with a cumbersome
lengthy process where they put out a
request for applications you wind up
with a contract with a huge contractor
based out of Washington DC we then sub
contracts three times and then finally
you know brings in people from outside
of Afghanistan to build a well in a spot
where the ground water is salty and
no-one's going to use the well you know
we saw these kinds of boondoggles play
out over and over again and what I take
away from that is that we have
eviscerated the expertise and capacity
on the diplomacy and development side
and we need to fix it not that we need
to throw this out not that the answer is
running everything through the military
which totally appropriately has
different goals is designed to affect
change on the battlefield in a
short-term tactical sense we need a
separate Corps of experts who know the
regions and know the pressure points and
are specifically tasked with looking at
the long-term implications years down
the line I think one of the reasons that
there is so much denigration of the
diplomat in our political conversation
is that the results of diplomacy do
require patience and can be less
immediate than things going boom and I
say that without any aspersion cast on
things going boom and the brave men and
women who dodge those explosions and are
in the line of fire but we need both and
both are important kinds of public
servants and Americans I hope when they
read this book and when they look at the
history of diplomatic endeavor of recent
American events they see that the
diplomat
deserves the patience that they need to
be afforded that if you give it the time
and understand that the results might
look imperfect and buckle down and say
okay we're gonna keep talks going no
matter how tough they get you very often
end up with results and results that can
save lives
[Music]